so so usually I'm speaking to college
students but it's a it's really a
special joy for me to get to speak to
clinicians because my life was saved by
DBT and I mean really literally saved
and I'm usually literally correctly and
not to mean figuratively so as a result
of my time in DBT I wrote this memoir
and I was lucky enough to have it
published by WW Norton which strangely
enough was my dream publisher and they
liked me too and here's here's how I
open the book border line means you're
one of those girls who walk around
wearing long sleeves in the summer
because you've carved up your forearms
over your boyfriend you make pathetic
suicidal gestures and write bad poetry
about them listen to Ani DiFranco albums
on endless repeat end up in the
emergency room for overdoses scare off
boyfriends by insisting they tell you
they love you five hundred times a day
and hacking into their email to make
sure they're not lying have a police
record for shoplifting and your tooth
enamel is eroded from purging you've had
five addresses and eight jobs in three
years your friends are avoiding your
phone calls you're questioning your
sexuality and the credit card companies
are after you it took a lot of years to
admit that I was exactly that girl and
that the diagnostic criteria for the
disorder were essentially an outline of
my life I don't have to read the
diagnostic criteria to you which is
something I usually do but I trust that
you know them so what I want to do
instead is just talk about my journey
from little kid in an invalidating
environment to grown adult who's been
working with these people you just saw
for three years and they continue to put
up with me so I was raised in a town
called Prairie Grove Arkansas which is a
town of a thousand people where
everybody's Southern Baptist so you can
see how that turned out
I did not meet anyone who was not quite
Christian and heterosexual until I was
17 years old the first time I met a
black person an Asian person or a Jewish
person was when I went away or a gay
person was when I went away to what I
call geek camp Arkansas Governor's
School in 1988 when I was 17 years old
and it changed my life because it was
the first time that anybody ever
validated me you know that was the first
time that I met other people who like to
do the things that I like to do I was
reading on a 10th grade level when I was
6 years old
and by the time I was 13 years old in
the eighth grade I took the SAT and I
scored well enough that I could have
gotten into a pretty decent college but
instead I had to stay in a town where I
went to school with the same 75 people
from kindergarten through 12th grade and
then inexplicably watch them get out and
marry each other which you know I'll
never never understand how that works
it's like didn't you see him like throw
up on your desk when we were 7 and like
you think he's hot I don't know what he
gonna do so that you know that was the
story of my life my school library I
found some pictures recently of my high
school library and only half the shelves
had books there were as many that were
empty as as filled and so when you live
in a place like Prairie Grove and you're
in sixth grade and everybody else is
just all they want in the world is to be
a cheerleader or does to save other
people's souls for Jesus or both to save
souls via cheerleading that was a thing
and you on the other hand are like I
really really like William Faulkner
you're not popular and I was the first
person it turned out to be I was the
first person on either side of my family
to ever go to college and because I
wanted to go to college and I lived in
Prairie Grove I spent my life hearing
that I was a snob and among the people
who told me that I was a snob were my
parents and one of the things that I
heard a lot from my parents as a kid was
if you would just try to not act as
smart as you are you would have more
friends I heard that a lot I grew up
hearing that so not only was I going
through this at home when I started
school I pretty quickly started getting
bullied because you know I went to
kindergarten and the first question I
asked on the first day was so we're
gonna start reading chapter books now
right and I remember I will never forget
what it felt like to sit there on the
industrial a flat carpet and have the
teacher hand out little cards with fuzzy
letters of the alphabet on them and hand
them all out and say we're gonna learn
the ABCs and that was the first moment
that I thought I was cool is not gonna
turn out well this is not where I need
to be and it wasn't long before I was
getting bullied and I got bullied by the
same seventy-five kids from kindergarten
through twelfth grade for example one of
the girls who would be one of my worst
bullies throughout my entire childhood
lived on a farm and she knew that I was
afraid of mice I've since gotten over
this but I was really afraid of mice as
a kid and she would collect dead mice
from the farm of which I guess they're
plenty and she would bring them to
school and so most days I would be
wondering when the dead mouse was going
to come out would the dead mouse be on
my lunch with the
mouse pee in my locker would she chased
me around the playground holding the
dead mouse by the tail
who knew another thing that happened
frequently was that the popular girls
would walk by and throw notes at my head
and they would say you're a snob well
they were alternately like you're a snob
and you're stupid which I never quite
figured out but you're stupid you're
ugly you're fat the only boy who could
ever like you is insert name of boy they
also thought was stupid ugly and fat and
by the time I was in about fifth grade
my nickname which followed me around for
the rest of school was paranoid Mouse
because obviously Mouse you get that
part and paranoid was that I would they
would all be talking about me or I would
try to walk up to them and they would
run away from me and I would cry and I
would say why are you doing this to me
and they'd say we're not doing anything
to you you're just paranoid so the two
biggest words that I grew up hearing my
entire childhood
we're paranoid and snob and when I first
found out that I had BPD which were
jumping ahead and then we'll go back
because that's the way I do things when
I first found out that I had the PD I
felt like I even though I felt like
someone had been following me around
taking notes I felt like I didn't
deserve the diagnosis because I hadn't
been traumatized enough and it took me a
lot of years to realize that spending
your entire childhood being severely
bullied and chased with dead mice every
single day actually counts as trauma
when I would come home and I would say
to my parents so-and-so called me this
today so-and-so chased me with the mouse
whatever the the answer I would get was
well if you would just start if you
would just try to not let them know how
smart you are you would they would be
your friends and you know in this sounds
like standing up here now at Yale that
sounds just insane and it's really it's
really wild to me that I'm that this is
even happening
you know cognitive dissonance but in a
good way
and it's it's really still amazing to me
to be standing in a room full of people
who are not only not all white and all
Baptist or at least I hope not but
people who think that learning is a
positive thing so thanks for that first
of all so I want to talk a little bit
about what it looks like
to leave behind that childhood when you
have gone through that kind of trauma
and then suddenly you're unleashed into
the world and I'll tell you about the
person who told me that I had the right
to be unleashed into the world his name
I call him I call him Phillip Thornton
in the book because he told me that was
what he wanted his name to be if you
write a memoir and you don't want people
to get mad at you let them pick their
names it works like a charm but his
actual name was Steve Nichols and I
don't think he would mind me saying that
dr. Nichols and he was the first
therapist who ever helped me when I was
16 years old but he didn't diagnose me
with BPD because he said he refused to
make diagnoses in teenagers but for the
sake of the insurance company he would
call it an adjustment disorder and I was
like well that sounds pretty accurate
I'm pretty much having trouble adjusting
to everything so yeah all right I'll
take that but the way that I finally
went into therapy when I was 16 years
old and the way that I finally got out
of Arkansas that's strangely enough was
that by the time I was 13 I had a pretty
severe eating disorder I was suffering
from anorexia and bulimia by the time I
was in junior high partly because I had
a boyfriend who told me I was too fat
and partly because starving is not a
good coping mechanism but it's a coping
mechanism it will keep you if you're all
you're thinking about is how much you
aren't eating and how much you wish you
could be eating and what you would eat
if you could eat and what you might
throw up the next time you do eat your
do you have less time to think about how
much everybody hates you and how much
you hate yourself so the eating disorder
worse and worse until finally one day my
mother caught me sitting in my closet
and I'd been doing this for quite some
time before she found me sitting in my
closet naked emaciated with a Sharpie
writing all the insults that anybody had
ever said to me all over my body and
this was the thing I would do I would
sit in my closet at night and I would
write words on myself the worst ones on
my face backwards and I would write ugly
fat stupid bad dog I call I started
calling myself a dog and I started
taking my food my dinner into the
bedroom with me to have dinner in my
bedroom so that I could get down on my
hands and knees and lick it out of a
bowl because I didn't think I deserved a
fork and you know nobody noticed nobody
noticed in my family that I was doing
this but finally one day my mom walked
into my bedroom and she saw me in my
closet grating on myself and she took me
to see Steve Nichols and Steve Nichols
had gone to college you know he'd
actually gone and gotten a PhD which I
thought was the most sophisticated thing
ever in the world short of Woody Allen
movies I was watching I was watching a
lot of Woody Allen movies and I thought
that in New York Jew was the absolute
most sophisticated thing anybody could
ever possibly be and second to that was
a psychologist with a PhD and Steve
Nichols started therapy with me by
handing me a book and saying I heard you
like books and I said I do I do like
books and he said this is the book that
I want you to take with you
this is my gift to you and it was gift
from the sea by Anne Morrow Lindbergh
and it I don't know if any of you have
read it but it's a beautiful little book
about a woman who escapes and goes off
on her own and does what she wants to do
and becomes an adventurer and an
explorer and he said this is you we just
have to make you stop throwing up
everything you eat so you can get there
and I was absolutely in love with him I
thought he was the most amazing person
in the world he became my escape and he
wasn't doing anything like dB
hehe was just telling me stories from
his own life he would he would tell me
he'd gone to Tulane University this will
be relevant later he gone to Tulane and
while he was there in the 1950s he'd
fallen in love with a stripper and her
name was wildcat Frenchie and he would
tell me stories about how he is one of
his great regrets was that he not only
lied to wildcat Frenchie and told her
that his name was Philip Thornton which
is how he got the name but he also he
judged her because she was a stripper
and he was a college student and he said
to me no matter who you are and where
you are and where you come from we're
all equal and what this means for you is
that you have an equal right to an
education you have as much right to get
out of Prairie Grove and go educate
yourself as anybody in the world and in
fact I think it would be good for you to
go see the world and to go learn more
stuff from people who also value
learning when I told my mom this she got
really angry and she called him and told
him he needed to stop being so
unrealistic and filling my head with
these ideas that would cost a lot of
money and so every time I would come
home from therapy feeling like somebody
understood me my mom would tell me what
a snob he was first she'd want to know
what he said what did you say what did
you talk about and then she would tell
me that that was all well and good for
people who have wrote for people from
Fayetteville which was the college town
half an hour away where I went for his
you know which might as well have been
like yeah I don't know some big fancy
place which it isn't but it's you know
it's better than Prairie Grove and she
would tell me that that I shouldn't
listen to him because he was a different
kind of person than we were and I said I
want to be that kind of person and she
said well we don't have enough money and
she was very angry because she felt like
he was teaching me to be secular and to
not love Jesus
and I had been told my whole life that
if you were feeling depressed if you had
a mental illness that was actually just
sin and the way that you got rid of it
was that you prayed more this meant that
I spent my junior high years on my knees
watching the 700 club and praying for
somebody's liver thinking that it was
gonna make my depression go away you
know like please Jesus Pat Robertson
says that you know you can fix this
ladies spleen and while you're at it can
I please stop getting chased with mice
you know that was that was junior high
so it was good times and to fast-forward
a bit I did get out of there I did end
up going to college and I did end up
going to grad school but while I was
doing those things the VPD symptoms were
getting worse and worse and worse and I
kept going to the student health centers
and because that was what I could afford
and I had stopped seeing Steve Nichols
because I wanted him to think I was well
I wanted him to think that when I got
out and went to college that was that
and he had cured me I couldn't bear to
tell him that I was still dealing with
you know huge ridiculous completely out
of proportion anger which was just
getting worse I couldn't tell him that I
was still getting bullied in college
because I couldn't stop crying and
following people around and begging them
to like me I I couldn't say that in fact
things were getting much much worse and
the first time that I went to the
Student Health Center at the University
of Arkansas in Fayetteville the first
time that I went to the Student Health
Center and explained what was going on
the doctor said to me are you having
mood swings and I said well yeah of
course you know like one minute
everything's great in the next minute
everything's terrible and I'm crying and
I'm driving people away and that makes
me angry and I punch walls and yes you
could call that mood swings and for the
first time in a period that would last
15 years he said to me that's bipolar
disorder and he put me on lithium I
gained 40 pounds in less than four we
I stopped going to class I couldn't move
I couldn't get off the couch I remember
my roommate coming in one day and being
like what's up with how you've just
turned into a tofu on the couch all the
time there was one night when I couldn't
find my keys and so I crawled around on
the floor for two hours looking for them
because I was so out of it I couldn't
remember where I had looked but I had a
watch on and I'd be crawling around and
I'd noticed that another 15 minutes in
passed and I'd be like I still can't
find my keys so that was lithium but I
wasn't having mood swings you know like
you don't have reactive BPD mood swings
when you don't leave the couch I mean
you can but not like when you're out in
the world ultimately I realized that it
was important to me to stay in school
and to get my degree and I just stopped
taking lithium thus began 15 years of
constantly being diagnosed as bipolar
and by any number of college health
centers and this was the late 80s early
90s I finished my undergraduate degree
in 93 and my masters in 97 so throughout
those years I was constantly getting
diagnosed as bipolar I would start
taking the meds the meds would have bad
side effects I'd go off I'd try to kill
myself I'd go back to the doctor and I
get more meds between the time that I
was 19 then time I was 35 I was on 29
different psych meds none of them worked
none of them I still was angry all the
time I still was punching walls I still
was one time I got mad at the student
parking attendants at the University of
Arkansas because they gave me a ticket
for being parked illegally and as they
walked away I swerved at them just to
scare them and the next day the campus
police came into my physics class hauled
me away and fingerprinted me and I had
to go before the Dean two months before
I graduated to determine whether or not
they felt I was safe to remain on campus
and get my degree this was my life and
it kept going on like this and it just
it was just years and years of going in
circles of
kind of getting better usually because
somebody liked me you know if I had a
boyfriend things were cool if somebody
if somebody said to me you're an
acceptable human being enough for me to
date you then everything was fine until
they saw me have a huge rage attack and
they dumped me and I tried to kill
myself and I ended up back in the
hospital so it was just 15 years of meds
and bipolar diagnosis and going off the
meds and trying to kill myself or trying
to hurt somebody else and going back to
the hospital and or doctor and getting
more meds and it was just that was my
life for 15 years and it wasn't getting
better it was getting worse I got my
master's degree at the University of
Cincinnati College of Art and I started
that program in 1994 when we had this
magical new thing called the Internet
and they wanted in this program that I
was in that my Master's is in it's
called new media art which is now really
really old media and I'm in a lot of
debt because of it so that's that's how
that turned out like I'll never own a
home but I know a whole lot about 3d
studio in 1994 so I was I was in this
program and I learned what webcams were
and at the time the only kind of webcam
that existed and some of you may
remember this because you're not 19 year
old college students pardon me I should
have brought water up here anyway so the
only kind of webcams that existed at
that time were those little round
Logitech quick cams do you guys remember
these and they were black and white but
they were this bless you they were this
wonderful tool that we were all trying
to figure out what were the art-making
implications what's cold too what were
the art-making implications of webcams I
got out of grad school in Cincinnati and
I was lucky enough to get a job teaching
at City College of New York and so I
moved to New York City and this was 1999
I moved to New York City and while I was
in the office when
in the of the art department I was going
through some magazines that my boss had
on her desk and one of them was I don't
even know if this still exists but back
then it did it was called Yahoo internet
life do you see anybody remember this
magazine and on the cover of the
magazine was a woman named Anna vogue
who does anybody know on a vogue it's a
long shot but on a vogue and Jennifer
Ringley of Jenny cam we're the first
people who had webcams they were the
first cam girls which is really a word
that I just load but we'll use it
because it's what we were so on a vogue
had this website where instead of just
doing what Jenny really was doing and
sitting in front of her webcam you know
just letting people see whatever
happened in her life whatever
coincidental thing happened ah no is
actually taking these webcams and really
trying to make art out of them the
technological capabilities of webcams at
that time where that they could upload a
still image every 30 seconds so I logged
into honest site that night and she had
a little grid of four cameras each
uploading a different image every 30
seconds that and they were in different
locations in her apartment and the first
thing that I ever saw there that was
really this revolutionary piece of art
for me for some reason that you know
would start me down the path to actual
hell is if I hadn't been on the path you
know it was just practice hell that I
was on the path to before and there was
when I logged in there was a bowl of
plums and one of the cameras was pointed
at a table with a bowl of plums and I
kept watching and 30 seconds later it
was a bowl of plums and a pit she'd
eaten one thirty seconds after that two
pits 30 seconds after that until the
whole Bowl disappeared and I thought
this is amazing this is sequential
time-based art this is the thing that I
was studying and this is exactly what I
want to do so because I was fresh out of
grad school getting all these credit
card offers and I got an offer from
Discoverer to give me $15,000 $15,000
worth of
plastic and I took the $15,000 card and
I charged the entire thing buying
webcams for my apartment I was married
at the time and I didn't tell my husband
what I was doing I just came home and
said look honey here $15,000 worth of
webcams I set them up all over the
apartment and I started broadcasting I
was doing exactly what on a bug was
doing I was making art right there's
only so much time that you can pull off
a facade whether it's in life or in 30
seconds still uploads I got invited
based on this webcam to go to South by
Southwest in Austin Texas and to speak
on a panel about webcam art this was
2001 the cam has been running for a
little over a year and I went to this
panel and while I was there I took some
ecstasy and meta boy you can see where
this is going this is one of those no
good can come of that kinds of stories
so didn't matter that I was married he
was cute and things weren't going so
well with my husband who was I can't
imagine why upset that I had charged
$15,000 worth of webcams and was
broadcasting his life every 30 seconds
and I went to South by Southwest I met
this guy I slept with him I came home I
left my husband and I got another credit
card so that I could start going to DC
where this guy lived and visiting him
every weekend so I would do that and for
about six months it went really well
my husband moved out I was still running
the webcams I couldn't afford my
apartment I was in massive debt that
some guy loved me so I was going and I
was visiting him and things were going
you know okay you can look normal one
for two days a week if you try really
hard and one night I was at his house
and he wasn't there he'd gone out to do
something you know he was gone for a few
minutes and I found a photo album on his
bookshelf was going through his
bookshelf which is what I will be doing
if I'm alone in your house ever
and I was going through his books and I
found a photo album and I opened up the
photo album and I saw pictures of his
ex-girlfriend and I absolutely
completely and utterly lost it
I pulled the photo album apart I ripped
up all the pictures I threw them on the
floor I took all the pictures he had in
frames and smashed them so there's a
glass all over the floor that wasn't
enough so I started pulling books off of
his shelves and ripping out all the
pages and when he came home I was
sitting in the middle of the floor in
the middle of all of his destroyed stuff
with a piece of glass in my hand going
why don't you love me
why wasn't I enough that you would have
thrown all of those away needless to say
he was a little upset and I of course
was like why are you mad at me why are
you mad at me promise me you won't leave
me you're not gonna break up with me are
you and he was like no no everything's
fine yeah you can see where this is
going I go home the next day I get back
to New York I log into my email and
there's an email from him breaking up
with me
it doesn't matter how insane your
girlfriend is it's really not okay to
break up with her by email so if any of
you are considering this don't my
husband was gone my boyfriend had broke
up with me I had trashed his house and I
decided that that was it I I was done I
was done living I was done hurting I was
done with the years and years of therapy
and hospitalizations that didn't work
and meds that just made it worse you
know or certainly didn't make me better
they made me fatter which is not a lot
of fun when you still have an eating
disorder and I went into the bathroom
that night I pulled the webcam into the
bathroom with me and I took every pill
in the cabinet of which there were lots
and lots because I had plenty of
medications that I hadn't finished
taking my webcams the last picture that
they recorded
was me with my head in the toilet and
pills all over surrounding me and that
picture will haunt me for the rest of my
life because the internet never forgets
this is what I'm doing to try to come
back that picture this is what I'm doing
to say [ __ ] you to that picture and to
all the people who think that it's okay
to torture someone and make fun of
someone for trying to kill themselves I
ended up in the hospital someone someone
who was watching the webcam saw me
someone who was not my boyfriend who
also was watching and someone in New
York saw what was happening and they
called the paramedics and they came and
they carried me out mmm I spent three
days in the ICU unconscious
my parents found out what had happened
because my ex-husband called them and
when I finally woke up three days later
attached to all these beeping things all
these machines my mom was sitting at the
foot of the bed and the first thing I
thought when I woke up was not oh my god
I tried to kill myself Here I am in the
in the hospital it was my parents spent
so much money that they don't have to
get here to be with me why would they do
something so expensive for someone so
undeserving and the first thing I said
when I woke up was I'm sorry for how
expensive this is I'm sorry I cost you
money I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
apologizing used to be what gave me the
only kind of skin that I had I started
calling myself the cheese grater girl
early on because I felt like I didn't
have any kind of barrier between me and
the world
I felt like anything could get in and
infect me and the one shield I had was
to apologize over and over and over
again I'm sorry for existing I'm sorry
for being ugly I'm sorry for being fat
I'm sorry for not being good enough to
date I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
not the last girl like I'm not as good
as your last girlfriend I'm sorry I'm
too fat I'm too ugly
anything that I could possibly apologize
for I would apologize for Ani DiFranco
who I mentioned earlier saint ani says
every tool is a weapon if you hold it
right and that's apologies were both my
tool and my weapon
they were my way of putting a barrier
between me and other people because if
you apologize enough people don't in
fact forgive you they get sick of you
and they stop wanting to hear it because
they know that no matter how much you
apologize it's just gonna happen again
my mom went out and talked to the doctor
at the hospital they came out of ICU
they transferred me to psych and my
parents talked to the psychologist who
had admitted me who had been seeing me
and I saw them out in the hallway I had
a window I could see through and I saw
them out in the hallway talking to this
person and I thought maybe they're gonna
finally understand maybe somebody's
gonna finally say something that will
make them understand what I'm going
through and when my mom came back into
the room I said what did he say and she
said he says things aren't as bad as
you're making them out to be you're just
making things into a big deal I had
tried to kill myself and it wasn't
enough to be viewed as a valid big deal
it was just you're making things a big
deal why don't you try to be less crazy
why don't you try not to let people see
how smart you are why don't you quit
complaining so I was in therapy at the
time I was always in therapy I can't
even begin to count how many therapists
have fired me for being a suicide risk I
couldn't even begin to count and the
ones who who didn't I walked out on
because they didn't care enough about me
I would walk out on them for saying that
we had to end the session when I was
obviously crying and hurting I had
absolutely no sense of boundaries
whatsoever because I had spent my entire
life begging somebody to see me and hear
me
listen to me and validate me and just
tell me that they loved me and when I
got out of therapy are out of the
hospital rather I went back to my
therapist and she said what so many of
them have said which is I can't see you
anymore you're too much of a liability
so those were the first words I heard
after the hospitalization in which I
heard you're not really things aren't
really as bad as you think they are
you're just being dramatic dramatic oh
my god if I had a dollar for every time
but what that therapist did that was
different
was that after she said I can't treat
you any more she said these are the
people who can and she handed me a card
with the phone number of the DBT program
at New York Presbyterian Hospital and I
said what's this and she said this is
treatment made especially for people who
have borderline personality disorder
this is not bipolar disorder that I'm
looking at this is BPD and she read me
the diagnostic criteria and I realized
as she read them what this was because
they had seen it in the DSM which I love
to read for fun and I know it's like a
party game diagnose your friends and I
said I said oh I know that one that's
the one that's incurable I don't want to
have that one and she said no it's it's
not incurable anymore
so I went to DBT and the day that I went
to my first DBT appointment was 2005 I
was 34 years old and I was so exhausted
that I stood outside New York
Presbyterian Hospital and I looked up at
the facade and I said I'll give this six
months and if I still hurt this much in
six months I'll jump off a building you
know I don't care what I have to do no
more pills no more of this whatever I
have to do to die for sure I'll do it
but I'll give it six months and I ended
up giving at 18 months and I marked a
passage in my book
that explains a little bit about what it
was like so I'm talking about suicide
attempts and and dysregulation and so
forth
DBT changed all that at least for me
because of two things the focus on the
dialectic or gray area between good and
bad and the strict adherence to the
rules required one of the things you
hear over and over again in DBT is that
as long as you haven't been hit by a
piano you're able to get yourself to
therapy many times I've heard those in
DBT say I just couldn't get here and
therapists respond no you just didn't
want to dvt therapist loved to talk
about mood dependent behavior and tell
us frequently that we have the power to
act opposite to those moods
at first we fight no you don't
understand he broke up with me she
called me a [ __ ] I failed a test a job
a relationship a person I was paralyzed
the DBT response could you move your
arms and legs yes then you weren't
paralyzed this is of course infuriating
and our response to being infuriated is
to thrash and wail and rend our garments
when we do this our therapists sit
quietly and wait for us to stop and
eventually seeing that we're not getting
a response we stop the ability to stop
is nothing short of miraculous to us and
before long we see that given a choice
feeling good is way preferable to
feeling shitty the outbursts get less
frequent we learn to calm ourselves down
sometimes than most of the time and even
if we relapse and lose it completely our
therapists stick with us unless we hurt
someone else or fail to show up we can't
get kicked out of treatment my program
at Payne Whitney had a very strict
three-strikes-you're-out policy and if
you were more than seven minutes late
that was a strike seven minutes and
thirty seconds and they wouldn't let you
in the door period but as long as we
showed up of which we were surprised of
surprises capable our therapist wouldn't
leave us they would refuse to see us for
24 hours after a suicide attempt
teaching us that suicide attempts had
consequences but they would never refuse
to see us
simply for being difficult they expected
us to be difficult and they didn't
abandon us that for me was the most
astounding aspect of treatment and the
one for which I am most profoundly
grateful so get off the stage shut up I
know I can't order lunch in less than
10,000 words and say it's a little yeah
we're out of time okay then I was going
to talk about something else but I'm
gonna say this one last thing because
it's the thing that I always want to say
to clinicians and it's the one thing my
DBT therapist did wrong amidst all the
things she did right when I started to
modify my body to get tattooed it was in
order to build myself a skin
I have never I'll be 43 years old
tomorrow and I have never thought
anything about me was in any way
beautiful except this because now I have
a barrier and I can look at this and I
can see the color and I can know that
that means that my skin is separate from
the outside world and that it actually
can't be gotten into when I would come
into DBT with a new tattoo my therapist
would always inevitably say tell me
again how this isn't self-injury so if
you're treating with someone if you're a
DBT therapist and you're treating
someone like me who feels the need to do
something like this what I want to
finish by asking you is just to please
be slow to pathologize difference
because we have our own ways of coping
outside of you but we're using what you
teach us it's just that sometimes we
interpret it in sort of interesting ways
so that said I'll shut up I'll let you
ask me questions and thank you thank you
for letting me be here
you